die frage die sich jetzt stellt ist eben
echt oder fake also ich hab schon mal
gesagt servus s kids von herzlich
willkommen zu einem etwas
außergewöhnlichen video und zwar möchte
ich heute mit euch ein bisschen über die
angebliche oder eventuell auch
tatsächliche spende reden die gestern
abend sich angebahnt hat in einem
livestream allererstes sie heute wieder
aus dem papa schlumpf aber gut da kommen
jetzt nichts machen
dazu habe ich jetzt einfach hier den
modus jump league gewählt weil ich ihn
ganz gut spielen kann auch gerne spiele
und ich irgendwie keine ahnung alle
andere machen 1 kommentar es auf ihr
wisst schon wie ein sieg aber da habe
ich keinen bock drauf
ich möchte heute die geschichte erzählen
und zum euch ein paar infos dazu geben
wie das alles so gelaufen ist wie es
dazu kam
und natürlich auch wie es weitergeht wie
jetzt der status quo ist also bis jetzt
momentan aussieht echt oder nicht echt
alles klar dann lasst uns ganz vorne
anfangen
ich habe mir dazu ein paar notizen
gemacht wenn es zeitlich reichen sollte
werde ich am ende dazu noch ein paar
fragen von euch rechnerei nehme ich habe
ihn öfter gefragt habt ihr noch fragen
dazu die noch beantwortet werden sollten
welche natürlich nur insofern machen als
diese fragen der nicht von mir
beantwortet wurden wenn ich die schon
beantwortet macht natürlich keinen sinn
so alles da er mich jetzt auch nicht an
den fragen lang handeln sondern hier
nach meinem skript gehen alles klar
alles fing alles an ich werde den namen
der person die hinter dieser spende
steht nicht nennen einfach aus gründen
dass ich für den fall dass die spende
vielleicht nicht echt sein sollte ihre
privatsphäre bisschen schützen will
seine privatsphäre sei eine männliche
person und ich will dass sie dann dass
er den katastrophalen hate abbekommt die
hält weder des jahrtausends oder im
sitzen
das soll auch nicht sein so
deswegen halten oder so weidmann also
ich reden immer von dem spender jetzt in
diesem fall alles klar
alles fing so an mir ist die person
diese spender ist erst mal in meinem
team aufgefallen vor
naja vor eineinhalb wochen oder so circa
mir wenn er in der mir fällt es halt
immer auf wenn im tourbus in einem
stream sind
der war zu dem zeitpunkt turbo und war
ich immer ganz nett so deswegen habe ich
mir den namen gemerkt und da ist
sozusagen uns erst mal in erscheinung
getreten dann ging's weiter hat mir ne
pn geschrieben
ich würde dich gerne unterstützen
gebraucht bestimmt wird mal und so die
pop abo und hat dann als aller erstes
mal daran betrag genannt der für mich
schon astronomisch hohe summe war und
zwar da hat er schon gemeint ja ich
würde dir du brauchst du brauchst
dringend equipment durch den cooper stu
master ich würde dir gerne 2000 euro
spenden
so ging alles los ich damals schon
ordner [ __ ] das kann ich echt sein
niemand spendet einfach in der person
wie mir die noch nicht mal mega
erfolgreich wie computerspiele spielt
einfach so 2000 euro verstehe ich nicht
und deswegen habe ich das ja hab zwar
nicht ernst genommen so was mich dann
aber gewundert hat die person ist
relativ beharrlich geblieben hat dann
irgendwann kontakt kontakt mit
aufgenommen hat mit ihnen zu tun gehabt
unter anderem rucksack mit tomek den
vielleicht manche von euch kennen der
beim ihr auftritt relativ viel macht
meine tweets programmierung pipapo und
so weiter die ganzen bots hat mit dem
dann kontakt aufgenommen
so sehen das los dann irgendwann hat er
zu mir gesagt warum er diese warum
werden wir das geld spenden möchten zwar
gemeint er findet das beeindruckend wie
ich das alles mit schmitt im studium mit
youtube und mit parallel hinkriege und
gesagt ja ich selbst könnte was nicht
und möchte ich möchte halt damit meine
anerkennung zeigen und ich möchte dir
zeigen euch das gut finden was du machst
und das schiebe dann schon eher logisch
so und dann habe ich ein bisschen
darüber geredet irgendwann was er so
beruflich macht und wenn seine angaben
stimmen
zu seinem zu seiner beruflichen position
sondern laufbahn dann ist das auch nicht
ausgeschlossen dass man irgendwie so
viel geld verdienen kann das so neu
spende machbar ist für eine person
auch wenn es für mich und wahrscheinlich
für die allermeisten von euch einfach
wie gesagt eine astronomische summe ist
einfach irre so dass sein die diese zahl
also wie es geht
falls es noch nicht wusste es geht um
25.000 550 euro insgesamt für mich und
meinen bruder zusammen am ende
und ja die zahl ist einfach gigantisch
so und findet also ich wäre keine ahnung
ich bin nicht die person die so was
überhaupt mal für real halten kann jetzt
in nächster zeit sollte es dann
tatsächlich irgendwann bei mir auf
meinem konto auftauchen dann vielleicht
erst wird sich so langsam der
realisierungs prozess einstellen aber
momentan bisher ist es alles irgendwo in
der schwebe und so diffus ganz schwierig
zu beschreiben so dann geht's weiter
diese person ist dann auch unter einem
dadurch hält auffällig geworden im
positiven sinne dass sie an andere leute
einfach gespendet hat oder hat irgendwie
tomekk irgendwie ein server gehostet
irgendwie server ausgegeben dem und dem
was ausgegeben hat zac jedem zuschauer
von mir live cam prägung aufgaben
gekauft wohlgemerkt ohne irgendwie
wirklich kontakt mit denen zu haben und
da ich mir gesagt okay die person
scheint irgendwie extrem viel geld zu
haben wenn man so was machen kann und
das ist auch eisen ist auch einer der
punkte der mich eher noch an diese
spende glauben lassen glauben lässt ja
auch wenn es natürlich gleichzeitig auch
gegenargumente so weiter dann er hat mir
von der angeblichen spende an the time
erzählt die ja auch gemacht haben sollen
manchmal kann ich hier hoch allerdings
im privaten
die nicht an die öffentlichkeit getragen
wurde so das weiß ich nicht vielleicht
kevin wenn du das selbst hier siehst
kannst ja mal dabei heißt kevin digital
oder kannst du ja vielleicht mal
kommentieren und sagen das ist und dass
wir uns auflösen
wer ganz interessant zu wissen weil es
in der hinsicht natürlich ein wichtiges
indiz ist für die beurteilung der
seriosität dieser person
sodann ging es so weiter erst 2000
habe ich immer mit ihm gezeigt und er
meint so ja irgendwie ja 2000 irgendwie
so wenig und keine ahnung 2000 also
durchgedrungen dass er nicht so den
bezug zu geld hat weil er schon mal
übrigens zu viel verdient oder so und
hat er gemeint jahr 2000 wird eine
leistung gerne mit mehr würdigen so hin
und her hin und her warmlaufen teamspeak
vor ein paar tagen
und er meinte er ja 12.000 so und ich
auf den punkt er zeitpunkt bin ich aber
auch komplett ausgestiegen weil ehrlich
gesagt über 12.000 euro wie krank ist
das bitte
so muss ich auch mal gas geben müsste
was ich will einfach hier so und
irgendwie crazy und dann im stream als
ich bin die ganze land dann von 12 aus
einem jahr vorher schon kontakt gehabt
wohlgemerkt aber das war im stream nicht
von null auf hundert neue und ja wir
haben dann der vorschlag habe wie gesagt
und dann im stream kommt ihr auf einmal
so max will ich auch noch spenden
deswegen natürlich das von 12 für dich
auf 25 550 für euch beide zusammen what
the [ __ ] alter und allein diese summe
macht für mich schon eigentlich
unvorstellbar dass das echt ist muss ich
wirklich sagen dass es keine summe die
ich jetzt für real halten
in der spende und ich habe gestern abend
vom einschlafen darüber nachgedacht es
kann eigentlich nicht sein aber ich bin
erstmal ergebnisoffen immer so schön
sagt sie
wir finden hier mal und ja dann der
status quo ist so er hat mir ein beleg
für diese überweisung geben momentan bei
ich nicht beurteilen kann
wie ja wie echt dieser beleg ist sieht
auf jeden fall nicht nachdem nach dem
deutschen beleg aus ist aber die person
kommt auch aus österreich also wie
gesagt es ist alles so es hängt alles in
der schwebe man kann nicht klar sagen ok
auf gar keinen fall
genauso kann man aber auch nicht sagen
ja garantiert 100 prozentig es ist es
gibt berechtigte gründe von 214 zweifel
die jetzt noch nicht alle genannt habe
aber genauso gut eben indizien dass es
auch wirklich so sein könnte
beispielsweise eben die spenden an
andere leute da wird einfach krass
runter genommen
was mich fliehen so weiter im text ja
darüber hinaus hat einen extrem großen
aufwand betrieben
also es wirklich schon seit tagen
hinterher
und ganz ehrlich wieviel aufwand kann
sich eine person machen um irgendwie so
eine spende zur verstehe ich auch nicht
ganz also ganz ehrlich ich weiß es nicht
ich weiß es nicht
für dieser aufwand ist er noch in den
dies für mich dass es dass ich sage ja
das spricht spreche er dafür dass es
vielleicht doch echtes eventuell welche
person macht sich so viel arbeit nur von
throl wirklich also verstehe ich nicht
momentan wie gesagt ist der status
abwarten
er hat jetzt gemeint die überweisung
wurde getätigt von seiner seite aus ist
wird circa 24 bis 72 stunden dauern bis
das geld ankommt falls jemals was
ankommen sollte
das heißt ich kann euch in den nächsten
tagen mehr sagen wenn euch natürlich auf
dem laufenden halten ob jetzt kommt ihr
an der bratwurst im ziel riss älter wie
viel eingesteckt hatte
die frage die sich jetzt stellt ist eben
echt oder fake
also ich hab schon mal gesagt mein
momentaner stand ist ich kann es
wirklich nicht beurteilen es gibt pro
und contra argumente für die these dass
das ding echtes tnt geplanten deswegen
ich bin momentan wirklich nicht eine
situation zu sagen echt oder fake und
ich will natürlich ein bisschen glauben
dass es echt ist ist ja klar weil das
wetter über kasse über krasse sache für
mich so recht viel schaden sollte
wirklich über krasse sache für mich
deswegen bin ich auch vielleicht
bisschen unrealistisch in deinem glauben
dran gibt viele die sagen aha die video
zu glaubst daran aber leute warum nicht
ich habe schon gesagt ich möchte auch
mal betonen ich habe schon mal gesagt
dass das für mich an meinem leben nicht
fundamental nicht ändern wird wenn diese
spende jetzt nicht erfolgt weil ich auch
so zufrieden bin
und damit habe ich bin nicht zufrieden
und habe so ein video mit dem betrag so
viel tausend euro noch und ob ansonsten
bin ich halt nur zufrieden ohne das geld
aber ich hab gestern auf jeden fall
das kann doch keiner übernehmen jo aber
treibt ein zuschauerrekord aufgestellt
und zwar angehörigen so davor war mein
maximum 820 gestern 1600 leute da drin
und ich habe niemand der mich wirklich
niemandem gesagt geht irgendwo hin und
sagt den leuten bescheid oder so dass es
ganz von selbst entstanden so da kann
man mir auch überhaupt nichts vorwerfen
alles leisten ja und ich habe auch
meinen coach partnerstatus gestern
bekommen
das war auch eine sache auf die sehr
sehr lange gewartet habe ich mich sehr
lange gefreut habe und deswegen war
gestern per se für mich krasser tag und
darüber hinaus wird ja wahrscheinlich
auch noch in meiner und eurer erinnerung
vielleicht noch ein paar monate oder
sogar jahre verbleiben sei es dass ich
bin da echt ist oder es ist beides
eigentlich ein riesending
wenn ich zumindest für mich wie das
spiel das für euch ist könnte es ja
beurteilen schreibt sehr gerne auch mal
eure meinung in die kommentare echt oder
fake wie seht ihr das
jetzt vor dem hintergrund dieser
indizien das war soweit das wie gesagt
eure meinung in den kommentaren würde
mich sehr interessieren
aber eine sache bitte bleibt sachlich
und schreibt nicht nur wolf wird oder
[ __ ] was ich habe hat mich wie
recht gefragt wie seltsam menschen sein
können wie hasserfüllt und wie wir
einfach nur auf mich wieder profi
kombinierten wird wohl eher dafür hinten
her bekommen wird jetzt frisst alter
schwede soweit ist startet
what the [ __ ]
ggg aber dass auch nicht viele leben ich
warte jetzt einfach mal kurz und hole
ich dich ohne doch ein leben die runde
gewinnen das wünsche ich geil select bis
seine kinder von life jetzt drauf haben
es geschafft wird wie gesagt eure
meinung unten in die kommentare
das war alles was ich bis jetzt dazu
sagen kann habe ich alles abgeklappert
ja habe ich glaube ich eure fragen auf
twitter konnte ich jetzt nicht mal ein
bild das video war auch schon so gut
gefüllt mit informationen und statements
zu diesem thema wir sind uns wieder beim
nächsten video das gerne daumen nach
oben da und vor allem kommentar macht's
gut und show